Netflix has released the final trailer
for season 3 of stranger things it seems
to confirm a possible fan theory about
the seasons main villain and includes
more pop-culture references from the 80s
and early 90s here are 11 details you
might have missed first off the trailer
release the trailer came out at 7:11
p.m. Pacific Standard Time perhaps the
seven is because the new season debuts
in July and eleven after well that seems
obvious the trailer is sent to the song
confrontation in rescue a Philip Glass
song from the 1980s the trailer starts
with an ominous voice over you there's a
good chance this is the mind flayer aka
the shadow monster who we first saw in
season 2 which possessed will taking a
new human form
could it be mayor Cline played by Carey
eul's or could it be Billy more on that
in a bit this all suggests that while 11
supposedly closed the gate to the upside
down in the season 2 finale something
ended up staying behind what if he never
left
in another shot we see the gang
preparing for a showdown we see Jonathan
grab an axe and Nancy cocking a gun
Nancy his first seen with a handgun back
in season one she and Jonathan are
practicing in a field
Nancy proves to be a natural hitting a
cam with her first shot Jonathan isn't
so lucky which is maybe why he chose to
use an axe as a weapon
she also carries a gun in season two we
see Lukas inside the star court mall
practicing with a slingshot slingshots
are Lucas's weapon of choice in the
season 1 finale he uses one against the
demagogue and actually gets a shot in
with Elevens help and speaking of the
mall as we saw in the first trailer it
will be a major setting in season 3 in
the background you'll spot a number of
1980s brand logos including Burger King
the Gap JCPenney and Orange Julius at
the carnival if you look closely you can
see an old-school Coke logo at one point
we get a quick glimpse of wills arm on
his wrist is a 1980s nel sonic Qbert
game watch as always the show pays
homage to a lot of beloved pop culture
of the 1980s and this time the 1990s as
well the duffer brothers cited 1993
Jurassic Park is a major influence on
season 3 some of the shots at the mall
are clear references to this scene in
which Tim and Lex are hiding in the
kitchen from the velociraptors speaking
of early nineties references this new
evil-looking character is giving off
t1000 vibes from 1991's Terminator 2 you
might recognize him as the guy with the
gun roaming through the Hall of Mirrors
in the previous trailer there's a brief
shot of Billy's car speeding towards the
mall which seems to be a mirror image of
this DeLorean scene and back to the
future
this film was released in 1985 when
season 3 is set and the scene happens to
include the same vintage JCPenney logo
we mentioned earlier at one point we get
another glimpse of the mine flare if you
recall in the final shot of season 2
this creature was seen hovering over
Hawkins middle school there also seems
to be hints that the mine flare will
take another human form this season the
question is who will be the host this
time fans are speculating that it could
be Billy and this trailer is giving us a
few major hints that this is true we'll
speculates that the monster will attach
itself to someone again as he says this
there's a flash of the mind flayer and
an immediate cut to Billy seconds later
we get a close-up shot of Billy's
dilating pupil the brim borne
steelworks building is also swarming
with rats which tend to symbolize some
sort of outbreak so clearly someone is
going to be infected was there anything
we missed
let us know in the comments
[Music]